hey everyone this is Lucy I'm a
Solutions architect working at AWS and
today I'm excited to share with you how
you can get access to free Cloud
certification courses from now until the
end of this year I'll also be giving
away five free AWS Cloud practitioner
exam vouchers so make sure you stay
until the end of this video to find out
how you can claim a free Cloud course
and enter the giveaway okay so starting
off with the free certification courses
this is a cloud happy initiative by a
cloud Guru and plural site to help
provide free certification preparation
there's five courses available and you
can select one of these courses to get
free access to which you can use all the
way until the end of this year what's
pretty cool about this initiative is
that you are just been watching video
courses alone there's also a Discord
Community where you can meet others who
are studying the same course as you and
you can also ask for help during office
hour sessions you'll also receive free
study guides with curated learning plans
and resources to help you get Cloud
certified alright let me show you a
quick demo of how you can get access to
one of these free courses the first step
is to click on the Link in the video
description below this directs to the
cloud happy sign up page and if you
scroll down you can see the five courses
available for free let's say you want to
access the AWS certified Cloud
practitioner course you can click sign
up now and provide your details after
verifying your email address and
creating an account you'll be able to
log in and access your free course as
you can see this course has video
lectures that are broken down into
chapters and it teaches you the
fundamentals of AWS Cloud to help you
pass your exam okay so in the second
half of the video I'm going to be
sharing with you how you can enter the
giveaway for a free certification
voucher as a winner you'll also receive
one month free access to the plural site
skills platform which contains thousands
of detailed courses and learning
material to enter this giveaway all you
have to do is follow these Two Steps
step number one is to make sure you're
subscribed to this Channel and have
given this video a like step number two
is comment below with the hashtag
cloudhappy along with one piece of
advice you have for people studying for
AWS certifications this could be from
your own personal experience or maybe
just something you've seen online and
adding cards all of you to read through
each other's comments to see whether
there's any advice you can take for your
own Cloud Learning Journey the five
winners will be announced on the 24th of
October which is around three weeks from
now so best of luck everyone please let
me know once you've signed up for the
cloud happy initiative and I'll see you
in the next video bye for now